you have a big birthday coming up you're
turning 50 in January yeah yeah 50 is
rushing toward me and are you at all I
mean are you worried about it at all I'm
not you shouldn't be no it's not that
I'm worried about 50 so much is it I'm
just trying to do a semblance of being
healthy now because I'm going to be and
by the way I'm not like I'm not trying
to get fit or cut
I just I'm trying to stop my chin from
melting into my chest and forming like a
neck boob that's all I want to stop
happening so you know what I've started
doing what I've started doing the thing
that people do with a approached 50 I've
started hiking that's oh I'm just hiking
and by the way I'm not a man out there
chugging up I'm just walking I'm walking
is all I'm doing i'm basically mall
walking outdoors yeah and and there's
people out there that are also hiking
I'm on all the trails and then there are
people that are super hiking like it's
not enough that they're just out there
hiking they if they see a tree branch
they jump up they do pull-ups if they
there's a bench they'll do sit-ups on it
or they'll grab a possum and start
curling at it at all it's like it's an
extra exercise yes the men and women
that do that stuff by the way are
already gorgeous they are at this level
of physical fitness it looks like
they're it looks like they're training
themselves to become what I like to call
uncomfortable to like that's basically
I'm sorry there's no other way to
describe it it looks like
listen okay basically it looks like
they're trying to make it so that if you
have sex with them
it'll be like lying on a floor covered
in leg it's all exposed muscle and bones
and ribs I know I'm not in the best of
shape but a woman can look at me and go
look at that comfy ol beanbag chair I
need some ropey Fitness or climbing all
over me like Patton there'll be no
judging the next day I sleep till 11:00
we'll eat leftover Chinese food and
we'll watch the expanse yeah that'll be
perhaps what you will do it'll be happy
what about this what what about this is
one of those things that happens cuz I
passed that same 50 landmark and I was
like oh my god you you get pressure to
eat right are you are you eating better
now I did that you you you went through
the whole sitting down and consulting
about you've got to start looking at
what you're eating and what you're
taking it yeah my wife talks to me about
that yes so does mine yeah and the first
thing that happened all of my breakfast
cereal got very serious all of my cereal
overnight
deadly serious my five years ago my
breakfast cereal was fun the boxes were
primary colors and an animal mascot and
the back of the box there was a word
find or a maze of fun maze help sugar
bear get to his insulin cereal but first
the cereals have names like sorghum
Farms amaranth flakes and the on the box
it's a white background with a beige
ball with beige cereal in it and a
couple of sad blueberries there's no
word for there's no more amazing there's
a short novel about the organic farm and
the creepy hippie cult family that's
growing the cereal and they just go
Paragon it's it's sorghum farms we
believe in three simple things farm the
table leading locally sourced
ingredients and giving back to
the nature what we say when we burn and
it just goes on and on if you're going
to put a New Yorker article on the back
of my shoebox I'm already eating your
awful cereal throw I need to get my
heart rate up in the morning throw a
couple of creepy offensive lines in that
show because no one's gonna read it
anyway what do you care my throat like
at sorghum farms we believe in three
simple things farm-to-table eating
locally sourced ingredients and the fact
that Mexicans can walk through walls
when it rains every field of millet we
grow is fed by the bodies of three
drifters process and are sharing bar
like just something creepy throw
something in there to make me that's all
I'm asking for yeah yeah no it's over
for you and I'm guessing it tastes great
too
oh my god yeah it tastes it tastes like
cardboard that committed suicide all of
these breakfast cereal large boards that
I couldn't take it anymore
but I'm the cereals I ate five years ago
used to smell like a carnival on meth
like that's what they taste like so how
do you go from a fun meth carnival in
your mouth to I I can't do this anymore
like it
you